[Music]
i'm joanna williams
i used to work at the university of kent
i'm now
working as an author i'm the associate
editor of spiked
i've written a couple of books one is on
academic freedom
and one is a critique of feminism it's
called women versus feminism
why we all need liberating from the
gender wars i just want to start by
asking you why do you think sort of
ideas
and research big thinking is needed
today still
so i think it's more important than ever
to have big thinking and i think
to see why just look at what's happening
in politically
in the world today and it seems like in
this country especially
it's like we've got a real deadlock
between what's going on in parliament
um and what's going on politically in
the rest of the country
and i think some big ideas some
real debates are needed to push the
situation forward
because it's almost like in parliament
people are so used to just finding
technocratic or
kind of managing real solutions to some
of the problems that we're facing
in the world at the moment and actually
having some new ideas and thinking
bigger and being a bit more ambitious
about how we approach the world
rather than just looking to tinker with
the edges and just manage
problems a bit better actually thinking
a bit more radically
might help us in society today
so in your own work what is your
critique of feminism that you put
forward
so my concern with feminism was really
twofold
firstly just that the world had moved on
from the time when
feminism first became a really big issue
in the 1960s 1970s
the world's changed and i think the
position of women in society has changed
massively since that time thank goodness
and i think that's a really important
thing and i think we should be
really grateful to the feminists of a
previous era the women in the 1960s and
the 1970s
who were really championing our rights
to abortion for example
the right to equal pay right for women
to enter the workplace
i'm so grateful that those women afford
those battles
and that's why we can be here today and
i think for the experiences of
especially young women today you know
the world couldn't be
a better place there's real fantastic
opportunities for women
to work in whatever sphere they want to
earn as much money as men
to choose whether to have a family
work do both do one or the other
and i think it's so brilliant that women
have got all of these choices
i think the problem is our feminism has
kind of changed and not changed
to keep up with how the world's moved on
so
feminism still seems to have this
narrative that to be a woman is a really
terrible thing
that it's so depressing that the world's
out to get you
and that there's still so much
inequality in the world
and i think that's bad because it kind
of sends a message to women that
you know what there's almost no point
even trying because
things are going to be going against you
and the world's so tough and so hard and
you know there's going to be sexual
harassment you're going to be paid less
than men
everything's going to be really
difficult for you and on the one hand
that's just not true
but on the other hand it actually
becomes this terrible barrier
now that women have to confront this
idea that everything's going to be
against them um so then you look at
what's happened to feminism
i think too often it's really anti-men
in a very negative way which denies the
advantages that women have got so if you
look at higher education for example
excuse me for more women than men enter
university
far more women than men graduate this is
across all subject areas this isn't just
in one or two subjects
and yet the narrative on campus is often
about toxic masculinity
about how terrible men are as a problem
in the university and that's
such a shame you know i don't think for
young women men
are a problem and i think when you enter
the workplace men and women can
work as equals together men and women
set up families
together and i think this idea that men
are the problem women face
is just really really unhelpful
so my final point i'd make my final
concern with feminism
is i think too often it just becomes
middle-class concerns
if you look at the stories that we hear
about so often in the media
it's about women who work for the bbc or
women in hollywood
or women who want to be on boards of
directors
um women who are earning salaries that
for the majority of people in this
country
you know it's just unimaginable that you
would earn that much
money and yet it's these people were
asked
to be concerned about and i think the
two types of people
who are not in that kind of top five
percent of the population
feminism just has nothing to say i
imagine some people would argue that
whilst feminism has had its successes um
there's still
women are still fighting for abortion or
to get the vote and whilst
more women than men might go into
universities there's still less women
that are ceos
so there's like there's some sort of gap
that's happening so isn't there still
a need for feminism for
these struggles it's just that for some
people they've reached a point in which
these aren't struggles
yeah so that's a really really good
point so there are definitely places
around the world
where men and women do live very unequal
lives
so you talk about places where women
don't have the vote
so i'm guessing you're referring to some
countries around the middle east perhaps
but surprisingly feminism seems to have
very little to say
so when you see iranian women in muslim
countries or in muslim countries
kind of taking off their head scarves in
an act of rebellion
against what they see as an oppressive
religious practice
feminism tends to be very quiet about
that
and rather than coming out and really
championing these women who want to
rebel
against what they see as a patriarchal
religion
you know feminism kind of keeps quiet
and is a bit nervous
about appearing to be anti-muslim so
that's on the one hand
on the the abortion issue that you
raised yeah i think that's incredibly
important and i really really agree with
you
and you look at some of the um changes
that are happening at the moment in
america
um particularly in the southern states
where
abortion is practically becoming illegal
i mean
that if you put a six-week limit on it
most women don't know they're pregnant
at six weeks so it's practically making
abortion illegal
and that again is is i think appalling i
think abortion's so
important for women to have control of
their own fertility control of her own
bodies
but again you know feminism just doesn't
seem to be able to provide the challenge
that's needed to this legislation i mean
not all feminists by any stretch of the
imagination
but some feminists can't even agree on
what it means to be a woman
nowadays now if you can't agree that
being a woman means something in a
biological sense
that being a woman actually means you
have a certain biology
if we have to refer to pregnant people
for example rather than pregnant women
it makes it that much more difficult to
argue that it's
it's women who need access to abortion
um it's not
people who need access to abortion
that's one thing
and then you get what i think are really
quite ridiculous and backward things
that are being suggested to challenge
this like this idea that was raised by
one
actress and that women should go on sex
strike
until um the abortion regulation has
changed
and you're just like oh my god this is
the worst suggestion
ever because it kind of implies that sex
is something that women
don't enjoy just endure and kind of
give to men as an act of kind of
generosity
and it completely robs women of all
agency to actually say well
you know we enjoy sex just as much as
men we want to
have sex just as much as men it's not
something that we
kind of bestow as an act of generosity
it's something we can do and enjoy
um and and arguments like that i think
actually really set the cause of
women's rights back uh in a really scary
way and so how can we reverse that how
can we forward women's rights
if it's not within a feminist movement
in which it's historically and
traditionally been
pushed forward yeah good question so i
think for a lot of the
a lot of the the i think there
definitely are problems that women still
have in society today
but i think a lot of the problems that
women experience with the exception of
abortion
i think a lot of the problems that women
experience actually men experience
as well because we live together in
families you know
um and we work together as men and women
so i think rather than having something
that pictures men and women
against each other so rather than say
looking at gender pay gap actually
looking at how can we get more money
for men and women you know how can we
all be paid more
have a better quality of life have more
freedom to
make choices that lead our lives as we
want to
lead them how can we work together to do
that rather than
pitching half a population against each
other
and to come back to the points i was
making around abortion
in terms of women's rights in particular
i do think it's really really important
to assert that
um being a woman is a meaningful
biological thing
i think it's um really
a really terrible if being a woman
if you for example have to refer to
yourself as a cis woman
what you're saying is that being a woman
is essentially a meaningless
it's a socially constructed category
it's not something that carries
any real meaning and i think once we
start going down that line
actually fighting for rights in areas
where women do
need them exclusively for women such as
abortion
access to contraception everything
connected with reproduction
um i think you can't make those
arguments
if you deny that being a woman is a
biological reality
so does that mean that the onus is
placed on the
individual to fight for women's rights
rather than sort of the structural
forces that might uh hold back women's
rights
yeah no not at all not at all i would
actually ask for a movement
um that a political movement that that
goes beyond
just women that's kind of bigger than
feminism
so i i definitely don't think you can
make
you can make progress individually
although you know i think we all need to
accept that we have choices that we want
to we make we make choices about our own
lives
um we might not make them in
circumstances that we've chosen
but we all do have some choices that we
can make
each at each turn like say they might
not be the choices we want
but we all do have some choices but i
think the problem with feminism
is as a collective it's only ever faced
it only ever is focused on half of the
population
and actually think having a collective
politics that goes beyond half of the
population
is broader to argue for changes that are
in everybody's best interest
actually is really exciting because it
poses the potential for a much broader
a much bigger and collective approach to
politics
and what about those who say might
identify as a woman but they're not
biologically weren't born as a woman
would you be then isolating them from
fighting for women's rights
in the same way that perhaps like
feminism has isolated men from the
movement
um so for trans women i think
trans women can fight for their rights
and
if trans women want to fight for rights
they
can and should do that but i think it's
as trans women
rather than as women and um
i think a lot of trans women who you
speak to
actually agree with that point and um
don't want to be labelled or seen as
as natural women or born women or cis
women however you want to put it
and are quite conscious that that they
are not and that they don't want to
appropriate
the experience that women who were born
female
have had so i think trans women fighting
for trans women's rights
is great but they they don't need to um
label themselves as women in order to do
that
you talked about bringing men into the
conversation to do with women's rights
do you have sort of practical solutions
of ways of doing this or experience in
your own life in which you've managed to
sort of
bring the divide together um so i guess
and i suppose this is counter to what i
was saying about wanting collective
solutions because i guess this is just
my own experience but i think it's
experienced that's
shared more broadly by people in society
so
i have three children and obviously i've
had to negotiate
um work and often working stupidly long
hours or working away from home
with raising three children but i guess
the thing is that i haven't done that on
my own
and i'd be really lying um if i
pretended i'd done that on my own
it's been very much a joint effort with
my husband
as i think is not unusual i think
everybody every family um every relate
in every relationship
people do that they make those
negotiations uh there may have been
times in my own life where perhaps i've
done more of
looking after children and housework and
my husband's done more work
and then we've swapped around and i've
done more of the going out to work and
my husband's done more for looking
after children but i think it's not
um like a zero-sum game it's not like
we sit there with a tally chart and kind
of count
up you know well i've done this many
hours of
housework and looking after children and
you've had this amount of money
it's just a partnership and i don't
think
we're unusual in that i think that's how
everybody generally who i've come across
kind of gets on with their life people
muddle through and they do the best they
can
to try and make sure that the adults get
to do some of the things they want to do
and they do the best for looking after
the children and
i think the thing with with feminism is
it kind of suggests that you've got men
here and women there and gains for women
are negative for men and gains for men
are negative for women
and that's just not the reality i think
the reality for most people whether it's
as colleagues
or as classmates or as members of a
family
is that men and women just rub up
alongside each other and
help each other out and it's not like a
grand political project or anything like
that
but it's just everyday life and how
people get along with each other
and do you think that maybe moving
towards a world in which we
weren't recognized as women or men at
all would actually just ease that divide
much more like a much more radical idea
of not
having such separation i think if you'd
asked me that question
um four or five years ago i would have
absolutely agreed with you
and you know that was always my
kind of understanding of feminism when i
was growing up
that i wanted to just be able to do
whatever i wanted to be recognized for
i guess um my thoughts on my
achievements
rather than for you know she's she's
good
as a woman or you know she's um
written this book as a woman i i just
wanted to
be able to talk about the things that i
was interested in rather than
being as a woman now i hesitate a little
bit to
agree with what you've said about a kind
of genderless world
because i think it wouldn't be so much
about just saying
let's recognize who people are and as
individuals or as what they've achieved
rather than bringing it back to gender
because too often nowadays i am
concerned
that it means erasing
the differences between men and women
all together um
and yeah as i've already said i do think
actually recognizing the differences
between men and women is important
um but i think perhaps unlike some other
people who make criticisms of feminism
you know i i'm not kind of thinking that
because men and women are different it
means that a woman's
woman women are kind of naturally having
some maternal instinct that women are
naturally more suited to being in the
home or
kind of you have a child and immediately
everything about your life
changes and you never have any ambition
to work
or think again you know i really do
think that men and women can be equals
and can do everything um this you know
can
act the same in the world but i don't
think that means erasing the differences
between men and women
and so what would be sort of an ideal or
values that you
are aiming for because i guess one thing
that feminism
does bring to people is sort of an end
goal or the feeling of a movement in
which you're progressing towards
something
do you have like an alternative ideals
or values that
drive you forward yeah and you know i
think there would probably be
um ideals and values that 20 years ago
a lot of people would have labelled as
feminist so
i would like to see a world where my
sons and my daughter
can all do whatever they want to do
you know that there being a boy or a
girl a man or a woman
doesn't hold them back in any way
whatsoever that they can
lead happy and fulfilled lives in
work in hobbies and interests in
family you know whatever it means for
them individually to be
fulfilled and happy i really hope that
they would have an
absolutely equal opportunity to do that
my concern is that i'm not convinced
that is the end goal of feminism today
i think feminism has changed i think if
that was the
end goal of feminism it would actually
say we've pretty much
got there you know we pretty much are
at that state now i think the problem
for feminism
is that it kind of needs to dig up new
issues
to justify itself so it finds ever
smaller and narrower points to
expose um inequality so just yesterday
to give an example
uh there's a story in the newspaper
about air conditioning in offices it's a
story which has kind of rumbled on
for a couple of years um saying that
it's set at a temperature that's too
cold for women
and so women can't think properly at
work
i just think my goodness mate you know
really is this
kind of where we're at now that feminism
is campaigning to have the thermostat
raised in the office by two degrees
is this the biggest problem that women
or is this even a problem
at all or a problem that warrants a
front page story in a national newspaper
and as part of me just kind of thinks
well if that's where we're at
then great you know the world's a
good place clearly in terms of gender
equality
but the other part of me looks at it and
just thinks oh no because yet again it
does send this message to women that
the world's hostile to you and actually
you know i think if you're codes at work
put a jumper on
which probably sounds really flippant
but you know i know
men at work you find it cold i know
women at work you find it too hot
and you know you're never going to get
an office temperature that pleases
everyone
but this is trivia you know this is no
way
um in comparison to say a 15 year old
girl in alabama who
needs an abortion you know these are
just absolutely
such polar opposites in terms of what's
important and what's not important in
the world
and my concern is that feminism is too
often focused on this trivia
and not focused enough on some of these
really serious issues in fact can't
help with these really serious issues
that we're facing
amazing and so finally just uh we have a
lot of
from the feminist movement there's a lot
of sort of people that are idolised from
suffragettes to like beyonce
i wonder if you have like similar
people that you think should be known
more about or seen as
inspiring um role models um or who are
leading the movement
that you would want people to know today
or in the past
dead or alive so one of my favorite
of all would be sylvia pankhurst i think
she was just amazing and i think unlike
emilyne or christabel
her politics i think were much more
universal about changing the world
completely
not just wanting a few concessions made
for men
made for women and not just wanting
a few concessions made for middle-class
women but was actually
much more about looking at the
experiences of working class women and
men and how the world could be made a
better place for
all of them everybody and she's somebody
who i would very much look to as a kind
of inspiration
and do you have a least favorite
feminist that you think
is being idolized but shouldn't be oh
that's a really dangerous question i'm
not going to make myself any friends
with there so i
so i guess um i'm going to sound like a
complete [ __ ] here and i was trying to
avoid doing this
so i worry about i'm sure she's
lovely as a person um but i worry about
the influence of people like laura bates
with the everyday sexism project
particularly with the focus on going to
schools
and the platform of speaking in school
assemblies
because i think if you look at some of
the
stories on the everyday sexism site
again some of them are really quite
trivial
um and some they they kind of blur
together some
really terrible things so yeah i
absolutely want to say that some really
terrible things that have happened
but their individual experiences with
some complete and utter trivial things
like we had a party and
my boyfriend left and i had to tidy up
and you said well i feel sorry for you
love but
you know really this is you need to have
words with your boyfriend
this doesn't need to be on an everyday
sexism site for the world to know about
um but i think there's a particular kind
of demonization
of boys and again this idea that
masculinity nowadays we nearly always
see
being associated with the word toxic and
i think giving that message to
young men growing up i'm on about you
know 12 13 year old boys
to have this message that they are just
because of how they were born um just
because of the society they live in
almost through no fault of their own
they carry this toxicity this kind of
poison to other people
i think some really a really harsh
message
to send to young to young men on the one
hand
it makes it very difficult for them to
negotiate growing up in a positive way
if they're told they're toxic before
they've even
entered the world and done anything but
i think it's also
really hard for young women because like
say it kind of imbues
young women with this sense that they
are victims in the world
um that they need to feel sorry for
themselves
that again as i've said already you know
that the world's a kind of conspiracy
against them
and so even before they start out in
life and
go and meet challenges in the world
they're told
that the world's difficult for them i
think that's really unhelpful
but yeah i'm a way of saying well that
makes me sound like i've got some kind
of personal animosity
with laura bates i don't have it's more
just the the project and she's not the
only one
who does this there are lots of people
who go around and kind of give this
message nowadays
lovely thank you for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute
of art and ideas at iai tv
you